one of my favorite people not only to
just watch and cover all those years but
to be able to call a friend since then
and then have my duels with him over our
institutions of higher learning some of
whom are not as good as the other at the
game of football joining us here Pro
Football Hall of Famer Jerome Bettis how
are you JP good to see you at the end of
the last hour we're always talking about
reminiscing about our first Super Bowl
that we covered on NFL Network's Super
Bowl 38 in Houston and how we were just
11 weeks old at that Super Bowl meant so
much for us at the network to have have
that experience and we were just 7 weeks
old 7 weeks old when a perennial Pro
Bowl player any future hall-of-famer
raised his hand and said you know what I
will go to NFL Network for 3-4 days and
spend an entire week as a guest analyst
on NFL Network which just started and
his name was Jerome Bettis it was you
you were the first guy to do it
Wow you see how how its evolved from
from from that I love the idea I thought
you were amazing and really that's what
kind of gave me the Ferrari into warning
to do television because of the
experience that I had with you guys I
mean it was such a great time and we did
some things out of the box went bowling
those kind of things right it was really
unique I know we went bowling because we
try to say well what does Jerome like to
do outside of football and do features
on that we just had no idea you were
such a bowling snob you had to bring
your own ball shoes that's like a golf
for going to the golf course and renting
golf clubs right if you're a really good
golfer you the last thing you want to do
is rent golf clubs right you say you
know what you know they're not going now
I understand that that's relatable to me
but how is a bowling ball different I
mean it's how is it different because it
reacts to the ladies different you know
the the balls that you have that the at
the lanes are just regular plastic balls
the balls that that
they react to the oil in the lanes and a
spin there's a lot of how many how many
300 dog I got one 300 I got one 299 a
bunch of 279 s I mean right did I did
pretty well but I had to make a decision
my C my freshman year of high school yes
was I going to continue to bowl or was I
gonna tribe football come on now how can
you not do both I mean because you got
to be committed to one and I didn't
I've never played football before that
moment I played you know high school
mean out in the street with your friends
and my brothers my brother's friends but
I hadn't played any type of organized
football so it was new to me so I knew
that the odds of me trying to do both
weren't there I wanted to focus in on on
football where's the bowling hall of
fame it's in Reno Nevada was it up here
it used to be in st. Louis right and
then I know it's moved since then and I
believe it's in could you have gotten
into the bowling hall of fame actually
actually I am in the bowling hall yes
good question I'm glad you asked that
okay they have about your own the the
bowling hall of fame has a celebrity
wing okay and I was the first celebrity
yes into the
celebrity wing of the bowling hall of
fame come on yes that's a round of
applause who are the other celebrities
and they can now look this up that part
I don't know but this big is bigger in
McCracken in that too damn big ern with
his home over Munson the one-handed
Munson is he in there - right there who
else like you were the first you are the
doer you were the first yeah absolutely
it was in st. Louis and so okay right it
was when I was there I was in st. Louis
hit everything there and went to the
they had a little event there pretty
neat are you looking it up right now
Chris is there is there is there a
celebrity wing for the bowling hall of
fame and museum or anything like that
there are celebrity nominees which
include Justin Bieber and Bill Murray
and Taylor Swift is not in the bowling
hall of fame there is no subway there's
no crazy
actually they were nominees for 2011
that's the so in terms of you bowling as
a when you were is a professional
football player how many times did you
bowl after saying you couldn't play
because you had the flu and went out
till 2:00 in the morning and bowled
anyways like like Le'Veon Bell did you
ever do that Jerome did you ever do that
ever I never did that I never did that
he said he had a career highlight maybe
I would have left a career high yes
because they just tells me that you just
had a great time now if you say you know
my friend was in town they drugged me to
the lanes I was feeling bad and I just I
yeah I threw the ball down the lanes a
couple times so be it right right sue me
when he says I had my career game it's
like yeah and I could have had a career
game the next day
oh my gosh yeah that was not a good look
what is it what does it say about me
that I was more outraged by the fact
that everybody else has got to stick
their fingers in those balls that he was
going in with the flu
honestly I'm sitting there like come on
now you know one of those guys that
wipes everything down before I sit down
I'm really not one of those guys but
what do you find in 2009 when Swan was
inducted into the bull Tom Candiotti is
also a knuckleballer I wonder if that's
how he throws the bowling ball too with
his knuckles now that wouldn't be
predict now that would put somebody in
the Hall of Fame that you don't put your
fingers in just your knuckles that that
would be worthy
that would be words not wobbles it's way
down to the 710 split right into the
pocket Jerome Bettis here on the Rich
Eisen show all right so what do you
think of this the big Ben's gonna come
back right yes you think so you think so
absolutely did no doubt about it he's
coming and then and now he's gonna be
part of this offense where these young
receivers are gonna be what I mean it
just seemed that we were missing that
juju Smith Shuster had a wasteland of a
season because obviously your
quarterbacks going in and out he
couldn't stay healthy what a dreadful
season it was for him so what about this
team because it sure looks like the
defense we are we are all good in that
particularly the one question mark
obviously you know juju didn't have a
great year but I mean Washington came
and developed like you you want your
second receiver to develop so now you
bring Ben back you believe you've got a
couple receivers that are really good
they are they have got a couple
receivers it's really good you also have
have found a couple running backs that
are pretty good you don't necessarily
have that one superstar guy but you've
got a couple running backs that are
really good now you bring Ben back to
the equation he's the catalyst but the
biggest problem that the still has had
in the last five six seven years is that
they didn't have a championship quality
defense now you've got a championship
quality defense and you you saw what
they did with no offense right right
they would on a cusp of getting into the
playoffs right if you bring a little
more offense to the table which I think
being can do not only are they in the
playoffs they have a chance to be really
special in the playoffs so I'm excited
about this night I don't think what
you're saying is anything that we're out
of the realm of possibility I'm just
wondering about the defense so TJ watt
obviously took a major step there's no
doubt about that the rest of the veteran
presence Joe Hayden had a great season
as well who's the biggest addition do
you think to that defense that made it
make a big leap would you say right
there in the middle of the defense who
would you say is the guy that the
Steelers made a trade for the first time
in the lush history the Steelers into
the top ten of the draft to specifically
say this is the kid who is that kid that
did it
it's Patrick nope nope nope nope maker
Fitzpatrick came from here in the middle
of the season I'm talking about the guy
right there in the middle the captain of
that defense of the future name is Devin
Bush and where did he go to school Bush
he was just here in that chair yesterday
photograph on the screen right there so
when all said and done when you need
when you need when you need that helping
hand to use that James Taylor phrase and
you need that friend and who do you call
on you call on a Michigan Wolverine and
Devon Bush do you not sometimes the
phone is dead and you calling somebody
you just can't you can't get it yeah
can't get it but I will acknowledge
Devon Bush got a chance to interview him
early on on another show that we both
were part of the grind right the grind
one apostle and you were great on and
and got a chance to interview him in
that game and he was outstanding young
man I mean had a great time with them
yeah we joked around about the Notre
Dame Michigan thing but I
serious no he will he developed from
that from the first week of the season
until the end of the year unbelievably
well to the point where he was one of
the big playmakers on that defense so I
got to give you some credit you know
once every two years Michigan I mean I
think Ty Law may be
yeah he's the Hall of Fame yes Charles
Woodson is coming he's coming
once every same shoes it was like five
five oh we gotta fill in the gaps we
gotta fill in the gaps of Notre Dame
sending somebody in that situation yes I
am a man that knows when he's defeated
yes I was beaten this year yes so my
business manager supposed to have the
Hat for us he did not see he didn't even
show his face he but I was willing to
wear this hat well he told me that the
Hat that he made up had the final score
no he had the hat on there what I don't
know what the Hat is supposed to read
the following they're going to hell to
the victors valiant hill to the
conquering heroes hell hell to Michigan
the leaders and best
[Applause]
want me to do that I honestly can't have
thought of anything else that you would
do that would make me think that you
would not have to follow through on your
end of the way George's where and I
should have gone to Michigan hat on the
vaunted field of Notre Dame with
Touchdown Jesus behind you but do I let
him out of that end of the bet now he's
got was very epic actually any nailed
all the words he grew up in the state of
Michigan you know
he should know that was had to look him
up to make sure I was saying it
correctly for you also I'm getting
visions of like it was your own
practicing or ek yeah it sounded to her
that was great to say this thing man on
radio that's something that's gonna be a
forever home is buzzing I'm sure
somebody's name is pissed off that was
pretty great
that was great Jerome yeah very
impressive and I would never sing your
fight song years honestly I could have a
kid right now and he or she could be Bar
or Bat Mitzvah by the time that the next
game goes down cuz Notre Dame refuses to
play my school okay so let's talk about
new vasive you're wearing the shirt
you're walking around great tell
everybody what new vasive is and what it
did for you into my career I was
obviously taking a beating physically
and then as mark as I retired I thought
everything was good but I started to
realize that I was having some issues
and was having some back issues and the
pain just progressively got worse and
worse to the point where I needed a
solution and I started to look for the
correct surgery that I needed to have
and I found the right surgery and it's
called X lift then I was looking for the
right surgeon and found him his name was
doctor Uribe one of the best in the
world and so I had this surgery and it's
a minimally invasive surgery they're
going through your love handles and not
through your back and for me it was
about you know recovery you know the
outcome how was I going to be after it
was done three-month recovery was out of
sight and I had a few
which is a very trying surgery
significant significant so no problems
after was was incredibly blessed to have
had a great doctor great surgery
everything went well and now it's just
an opportunity to really tell people
that you know you don't have to live in
pain there are solutions out there and
and here to give my story and so what we
did was I if you go to new vasive comm
backslash the bus my story is really
there for anybody who's thinking about
and having some some back issues to
really consider all the options because
you don't have to live in pain yeah
there's so many people I'm sure
listening to is watching us right now
who have somebody or they might be
somebody themselves that have got back
pain and they're just maybe a little
nervous of not undergoing the knife
because I mean I can't say for sure
again new vasive calm / the bus to learn
about your journey the procedure and how
to find the right surgeon two more
questions before you before we send you
out into that porn beeping community
called Miami Florida
is it a safe assumption the way that the
Niners run the ball makes you like them
for this game or or or what do you say
here I'm a you know I'm an teary fan I
love Andy I want to see him win so
obviously I'm rooting for Kansas City
but obviously as a running back I love
the fact that San Francisco runs the
football unapologetically and they do it
in so many different ways you know they
do have the zone scheme but then they
can they do some Rams and some some
traps and stuff like that inside running
so for me it's fun to watch because they
get to the running game so many
different ways it's the exotic you know
Smash Mouth football if you will yeah
sure so I love to see them but I think
the bottom line in this game is the
offensive lines which offensive line is
going to hold up nobody's talking about
the offensive lines because everybody
wants to talk about you know hey the
quarterback and in the defense for San
Francisco but what it boils down to is
the offensive line that does the best
job if
francisco if they can run the football
against kansas city they win yes
if kansas city can hold up protection
wise and protect my homes then Kansas
City wins so I think the offensive lines
in this game they're going to determine
who wins a championship the proverbial
trench battle and then what a great
moment um a couple weeks ago on on CBS
when Bill Cowher got surprised unlive
television that he's going to join you
and the rest of the Steelers and the
rest of the men in the bust room at the
Pro Football Hall of Fame that was
pretty neat amazing he was he's the
reason I'm in the Hall of Fame what do
you mean because he believed in me when
some of the coaches on the staff didn't
in terms of feeding me the ball
consistently but throughout my career
there was a couple of times where they
could have gotten rid of me and they
decided to no we're gonna stay with them
but now that we're gonna stay with them
we're giving him the ball and I you know
I rewarded them by having some big years
when there were some questions about me
and my age and my health so coach Cowher
is the number one reason that I was able
to wear that gold jacket because he
believed in me believed in my abilities
so I am I'm so honored that now he's
going to be next to me in the Hall of
famous ISM it's incredible and that's a
great thing to put on a resume too for
people who might not have known that
story well coaching is about making the
right decisions and pushing the right
buttons and the fact that let's stick
with Jerome Bettis that's a pretty good
decision to say at least what what will
your busts say to each other as you know
John Madden says they talk to each other
what will cower and Bettis his bust say
to each other when the lights go what is
his bus is still gonna be asking me you
know am i eating good what's what's my
weight like he said he's still gonna be
on top of me so I I'm glad that
hopefully I won't be right next to him
I'll be down some so he won't he gonna
see what my bust is eating late at night
well also too we asked him point-blank I
asked him point-blank on the show like
do you want the smiling bill or do you
want the jaw
saying it and spraying it taking the
Polaroid photograph jamming it into the
shirt pocket of the ref you want that
Cour and he goes if I want to be talking
to my peers when the lights go out I
want that Cour no question absolutely I
will
I want that Cour as well the smiling
Cour that wasn't real nobody saw that
that's not a rest not real if you want a
real cow that's the real cow we saw the
other side in practice but game time I
mean he literally would I mean he'd do
all kind of things game time he was
fired up when I tell you as a former
player he knew what it felt like so he
would I mean he was gone so you had to
kind of have some you know some distance
if there was certain things that he was
getting up for and it was about defense
you know he was you know he was tense so
I want that coward on the bus because
then I know that he's in the fight
that's what he said that's the that's
the guy he wants into the Hall of Fame
and congrats on seeing your coach get in
and and a great rendition of the victors
man no no that was really terrific
don't say that of course you and by the
end of today by sundown I will have a
new ringtone it's gonna be fantastic
when you call me it's gonna be great I'm
gonna put some sunblock you are not
allowed to put that on your personal
Instagram or Twitter count on another
you are not allowed to pop said it right
now he's not allowed know that yeah I
know but I mean if you want to really
pay off the bet you look at the camera
and say I should have gone to Michigan
I'm glad I went to no today go to you've
a sitcom slash the bus follow him on
Twitter and Instagram at your own Bettis
36 when we come back Chris what do you
have for your news update over there you
got some good items yeah we got Richard
Sherman from last night some things
about the National Football League and a
major league baseball team has made a
managerial high okay so the Red Sox the
Astros have hired somebody correct okay
that's next right here on the Rich Eisen
show that rolls on with the news update
your phone calls at eight four four two
oh four rich poor Hayes massa
as well as Frank Caliendo still to come
here in studio for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app